It's no secret Israel and the Arab
countries have never had a good
relationship and they've always had a
pretty terrible one.
Three wars,
dozens of diplomatic conflict,
send all kinds of accusations.
The Arab Israeli conflict was one of the
hottest in the second half of the 20th
century.
So when you have problems with your
neighbors,
well you have a problem,
but if your neighbors are the largest
oil producers in the world,
well then you really have a much bigger
problem.
This is especially true when you
consider that Israel has always been
considered something of an energy
wasteland.
All attempts to find oil there weren't
been successful.
Now it is true that up until 1979,
Israel has a nice Aulani in the region.
Can you guess which country this was?
Well,
you might be surprised to learn that it
was Iran.
Yep,
that's right.
In the Times of the shower of Persia,
Iran was a close ally of Israel.
After all,
they both had a common enemy and that
was the Arabic countries for the first
time.
We see them arriving at Parliament House
to take over the range of Apis that
these countries and such a close
relationship that in 1978,
Israel offered the shower of punisher
help in building nuclear power plants.
Yes,
really,
however,
that all changed in 1979 with Khomeini's
revolution.
From that moment on Israel and Iran went
from being good friends too.
Well,
great enemies.
The thing is that Israel has always had
two main weaknesses.
The first is this bad relations with
countries in the region and the seconds
are the difficulties they've had
ensuring that oil supply,
especially when facing conflict,
the minister for energy in Israel
admitted in 2014.
This real situation is complicated.
Don't have diplomatic relations with
most of the countries from which we
import oil,
Yusef Paritski.
However,
it seems as if all of this,
it's about to change gift gift.
That is the definition Benjamin
Netanyahu,
Israel's prime minister,
gave to the latest discoveries made in
the Mediterranean Sea discoveries which
might change forever.
These strategic reality of the conflict
of region of the Middle East,
but now you are probably wondering what
might those discoveries beat?
Well,
pay attention to this map.
Each yellow piece represents the newly
discovered natural gas
fields
and these are not small fields,
either the last of them to be found and
known as Leviathan is one of the largest
reserves founds in the last few decades.
Israel has done everything they could
since 1952 in order to find oil or gas
in that territory.
Something that they could achieve energy
independence,
but I'm until the year 2000.
All of their attempts,
they were unsuccessful.
If you were 10 years ago,
15 years ago,
and I said Israel would find a big
amount of energy and be almost totally
independent when it comes to energy,
you would think that I am crazy.
We were the country of milk and honey,
but when it came to oil,
we've left it to our neighbors.
Not t beren boy Thomas Group.
However,
everything started to change in the year
2000 thanks to technology.
When a tax company,
Nobel energy founds the first reserve in
the open sea,
known as Mari,
be this first one,
it was small,
but it was a turning point because they
knew that under the sea,
on the sea bed that were surprises
waiting,
so noble energy kept exploring the
bottom of the sea and in 2009 they hit
the Jack.
They found it for you tomorrow reserves,
so you science was significance.
In fact,
the reserve provides Israel with half of
that electricity requirements last year,
later in 2010.
Well they did.
It just hit the Jackpot.
In the casino,
they won the lottery after spending only
$100,
million dollars in the exploration of
the area,
noble energy hits Leviathan,
an enormous field.
So now you're probably starting to
understand what's going on here,
a little best app.
It is estimated that this reserve is
larger than all of the ones found in
countries like Bolivia or Mexico as
well.
This is not the end of the story because
most of this area is still unexplored.
In fact,
the geological studies have indicated
that there is much more natural gas
5,000 meters below the surface.
Oh,
there is also oil.
Moreover,
the government estimates that the
Mediterranean could be holding a
colossal wealth in natural gas and oil
as well.
This falls within Israeli waters.
In total,
the government estimates that there
might be more than 3 trillion cubic
meters of gas and 6 billion barrels of
oil.
All right,
that's all well and good,
but what exactly is 3 trillion cubic
meters?
I mean it's not exactly easy to picture,
so you can appreciate the songs of this.
If these estimations.
All right,
Israel,
a small country of only around $8
million inhabitants could become one of
the top 15 countries when it comes to
natural gas reserves and in the top 20
countries when it comes to it
oil.
This is not just for Israel exports.
They've already started at the end of
2016 Israeli companies reached an
agreement with the government of Jordan
to become its main supplier for the next
15 years.
It's a contract will have more than
$10,000,000,000 between 50 and 60
percent of that money is going straight
to the coffers of the Israeli
government.
That's the right division of politic
view,
or in the next few decades,
the government of Israel is going to get
an income in the tens of billions of
dollars,
tentative estimations,
and I confirmed we would be talking
about hundreds of billions of dollars
and there's more.
It looks like Israel lacks continental
oil,
but there could be in massive quantities
of shale oil.
The type of oil that can be extracted
through fracking well,
they've already found the first
reserves.
This means that not only is Israel going
to achieve energy independence,
but it could even become a new energy
power.
Now you might know why ness and Yahoo,
it has referred to these fields as God's
gift.
A few years ago,
golden year,
the ex prime minister told this famous
joke.
Let me tell you something that we
Israelis have against Moses.
He took us 40 years through the desert
in order to bring us to the one spot in
the Middle East that has no oil.
Golda Meir,
well,
it sure looks like this is no longer the
case and to this discovery,
the fact that Israel is one of the most
innovative countries in the world and
it's entirely possible,
it could soon become one of the world's
wealthiest countries.
Oh,
it's also probably important that we
mentioned another player here.
Can you guess who were the first to have
an interest in these reserves?
It was the Russians.
Yep.
Again,
really Gazprom actually tried to buy
them.
This all indicates that Israel could
take part of the Russian gas market
share in Europe,
and as you already know,
energy means money and influence new
allies.
The international situation of Israel,
it's always been controversial,
was political conflict.
The UN resolutions,
the Israeli Minister of foreign affairs
has to work harder than Santa Claus on
Christmas Eve.
Consider the last events from the UN.
UN Security Council passes resolution
demanding end to Israeli settlements.
Well,
despite all of this,
the truth is that Israeli foreign policy
is stronger than ever.
Israeli authorities are determined to
put an end to their dependence on the
United States and these recent gas and
oil discoveries have certainly helps.
For example,
relations with their neighboring
countries have improved quickly and by a
great amount in 2010 relations with
Turkey,
you broke down almost completely when
Israel approached the freedom flow
tiller,
but now these relations at being healed.
This probably has a lot to do with the
fact that Erdogan is country uses up
massive quantities of natural gas and
they're important agreements with the
Russia will be over in just five years
and we already know how unstable
relations are lately between these two
countries.
Things are also working out great with
their other neighbors.
Egypt and Jordan.
Israel hasn't just become Jordan's major
gas supplier,
but the relations with Egypt are working
so well that shall keep the minister of
Foreign Affairs Watch footballs,
European Championship final in the
residence of the Israeli prime minister.
Further the unimaginable it could even
be happening.
Some are talking about reconciliation
between Israel and Saudi Arabia.
Israel,
Saudi Arabia are reportedly negotiating
economic ties.
Israel is also bonding with Tsipras
Greece,
which has surprisingly the come a close
ally.
In fact,
the Israeli air force is now training in
Greece,
but the really major change has been
from the east ends in this process.
India was key.
India has made Israel its second largest
arms supplier behind Russia in the last
decade.
India has bought from Israel more than
$10,000,000,000 of military equipment.
Their relations are so good.
In fact,
so this in 2015 for the first time in
history,
the president of India went to Israel on
an official visit.
All right.
Jump Modi to become first Indian prime
minister to visit.
I'm.
Let's just add one more thing on their
subjects.
Up until now,
Greece and India had been very critical
of Israel as a consequence of the
situation with Palestine,
so you can imagine what a step this was
for the Israeli Ministry of Foreign
Affairs and India is not the only one.
Israel is also building a close
relationship with China and they own
negotiating a free trade agreements.
It's the only Chinese businessman then
making strong investments in the country
and think even building a port in the
city of Ashdod as part of their Silk
Road Jack,
so their relationships developing with
Vietnam,
South Korea.
It really seems that anywhere in Asia,
Israel is a total success only we
haven't forgotten about Donald Trump who
for now mez committed to this.
It's our true friend over there and
we're going to protect Israel 100
percent
anyway.
There's still a long way to go for
Israel to become an energy power,
but if they do,
it will have a positive effect for the
area's stability,
which think would be a very good thing.
Indeed.
Israel is well on its way to becoming a
great country,
but there are still some things that
need to be dealt with like the conflict
in Palestine.
Luckily better relations with Arabic
countries could help in this matter a
lot.
So now what do you think?
Do you think that this new energy wealth
will contribute to the solution of this
conflict?
And if you enjoy this video,
please do hit that like button and do.
Click that subscribe button.
If you want to receive on your videos,
they come out twice per week.
Also do check out our friends at the
reconsider media podcasts.
They provided the vocals for this
episode that are not mine,
and as always,
thank you for watching.